une plage qui s'étire comme un croissant
de lune sous le soleil une eau
translucide et même un lagon intérieur
avouez qu'il ya ici comme un air de
tropiques
les savait très fin on dirait les
caraïbes pour moi on est aux maldives
c'est magnifique honnêtement les plages
ici sont encore plus belle que chez moi
au brésil à voir la plage les collines
est la forêt au même endroit c'est
merveilleux on se croirait au paradis
nous ne sommes pourtant pas à l'autre
bout du monde mais à deux heures d'avion
de paris au large de la galice
pour rejoindre les îles 6 sc leurs
plages de rêve bonjour bienvenue nous
embarquons au port de vigo au nord ouest
de l'espagne
premier départ de la journée allez on y
va vous allez avoir lille pour vous tout
seul
manuel est notre capitaine il fait la
traversée tous les jours depuis dix ans
alors ces eaux parfois piégeuse n'ont
plus de secret pour lui
oui c'est dangereux il faut faire
attention aux bancs de sable je suis
fils de pêcheur un jour le bateau de mon
père a coulé et aujourd'hui à chaque
traversée je passe au dessus de son
bateau je sais où il est il faut
toujours respecter la mer après 40
minutes de traversée nous arrivons enfin
à 15 km des côtes
j'ai spectaculaire clair comme du
cristal
incroyable
amandine une touriste française est
l'une des premières à fouler le sable le
continent semblent déjà très loin
derrière
barda c'est incroyable bien personne
on déconnecte totalement on s'en fout on
respire de nouveau
la playa del audace s'étend sur 700
mètres et a été élu plus belles plages
du monde par le journal britannique the
guardian sa particularité reliées entre
elles deux îles de l'archipel
à l'origine il n'y avait qu'une seule
île avec le temps et l'érosion elle
était coupée en deux la plage est le
dernier élément naturel qui relie les
deuxièmes
maria et guide sur les îles ce jour-là
elle emmène un groupe de visiteurs à la
découverte du lac intérieur seulement
séparait de l'océan par un pont de
pierre
on va s'approcher du lac voyons voir si
on a de la chance avec cette année
manceau el pais la regarder ça bouge
impossible à huy regardez un crabe royal
bravo vous êtes déjà un expert du parc
national de l'île un crustacé très
réputé dans la cuisine galicienne
mais celui ci comme tous les poissons
qui l'entourent ne finira jamais dans
une assiette ces eaux font partie d'une
réserve naturelle et sont strictement
protégée
c'est rempli de vie on peut voir des
bancs de poissons de la végétation sous
marine c'est comme un aquarium à l'air
libre un archipel sanctuarisée où seuls
1800 touristes peuvent débarquer chaque
jour pour limiter au maximum l'impact
sur l'environnement
il y a encore deux ans une poignée
d'habitants résidait sur saisine et
vivait notamment de la pêche et du
tourisme mais aujourd'hui l'archipel est
totalement inhabitée seul moyen d'y
passer la nuit se glisser sous l'une des
tentes du campement
sous une canopée nous abritons pour la
nuit nous faisons partie des rares
privilégiés à pouvoir admirer le coucher
du soleil sur les îles cias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lendemain nous partons à l'assaut des
contrées verte et montagneuse de
l'archipel
allez ça va valoir le coup
javier nous a promis l'une des plus
belles vues sur les îles au bout de ce
chemin tout en zigzag gardé par les
maîtres des lieux
regardez là bas on voit une mouette
c'est une maman qui garde ses trois
petits poussins les oiseaux peuvent
voler moi non mais là on est exactement
à la même altitude on a la même vue et
de penser à ça je me dis que c'est un
moment unique et spécial un
retour au niveau de la mer paul et jade
deux français sont venus pour observer
la faune aquatique
lawley turquoise est tous vraiment franc
magique une plage sauvage cacher
derrière des montagnes l'endroit idéal
pour passer dans l'autre monde
et découvrir ses habitants
mais ne vous fiez pas aux reflets du
soleil sur le sable ici l'eau de
l'atlantique atteint à peine les 16
degrés
c'est à dire qu'elle est très belle mais
elle aussi très froide et pour voir de
belles choses mais parfois faut prendre
sur sa magnifique et des poissons
partout à l'archipel que les romains
avaient surnommé en leur temps les îles
des dieux et qui pourrait bientôt faire
son entrée au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité